this program is brought to you by emory
university the president of Emory cap
Widow club it's a mixture of dance and
fide emphasis on culture it has a lot of
elements of being playful and really
being being like a mental and physical
activity there's a lot of music and
everything involved pretty it's pretty
amazing bring together a pretty wide
group of people my name is the Gunther
Raj Kapoor and I'm a junior at Emory
University and I'm an international
student I was born and raised in Kuwait
here I'm involved with the Hindu
Students Association we have weekly
discussions which are open to everyone
where we talk about different aspects of
our faith in it's really cool because a
lot of non Hindu show up because they're
just curious about what it
the lunar banquet celebrate chinese new
year and this year it's the year of the
rabbit at every is very involved and
they sponsor a lot of events around
campus but not only Chinese people but
also for other asian and non
one of their big events every year that
a lot of people are doing coming in
publicity chair for the African students
association last semester we had our
largest main event which is taste of
africa we had different performances
both student and professional
performances different food dancing a
fashion show one of the things that
we're trying to do is make sure that
different groups across campus know that
we want them to attend and take part the
office of multicultural programs and
services basically is the office that's
over all of the diversity litter much on
campus so we need group that was that
basically wants to kind of break out and
say i want to be a group that's for
asian pride they were simply top city
group that says i want to start at
cultural dance troupe that's what it was
all about it's like putting you in that
melting pot you gotta letting you find
yourself whether it be in one spot or 15
I'm from Nashville Tennessee the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University